this is a production of Cornell
University
so yes I'm going to talk about one of
our most favorite plant types today and
as I go through this what I'm going to
try and get you to do is to think and
and I'm going to put some things on here
that basically might change your
thinking might solidify your thinking
but I want you two to think more broadly
about weeds because I think a lot of
this has to do with some of our
preconceived ideas and and maybe some of
the things that we've learned over time
but I will just get into this and this
might be familiar to some of you not
sure but you know this guy out here he
sees not real old i sees laying down on
the job but you can see is quite
frustrated and you know asking them
about this new frontier are you kidding
me this is no new frontier this is the
same old thing i've been doing you know
for the past few years of my life so our
attitude towards weeds now I've I've put
this into I'm just giving broad terms to
conventional thinking and sustainable
thinking now these are not good or bad
this is just how we sometimes tend to
think so in conventional type systems
you know typically one hundred percent
weed free we know that they negatively
compete with available resources so
eliminating weeds is number one priority
and there's obviously there's a
relationship with economic losses
associated with those systems in more
sustainable systems or sustainable
thinking you know often its density
thresholds how many weeds are out there
can I can I get by with and are they
really having an impact that I need to
work with also plant diversity so the
thinking more broadly you know there's
these are plants they're adding
diversity to the system and also are
they providing an alternative cover
whether it's a mulch whether it's you
know something else that allows these
allows them to remain in these systems
but the impacts of weeds and through the
literature various studies good or bad
okay and this is somewhat conflicting
and again it's based on kind of your
thinking and and and what you're kind of
geared toward but we can think of weeds
is either they compete for resources or
they contribute to resources through you
know biomass or competing for available
resources they inhibit or assist
operations whether that's harvest you
know clogging up your harvester or you
know providing a mulch harbor insects
and diseases or support beneficials
increase agronomic biodiversity but
maybe lower diversity in our natural
systems where you see invasive plants
becoming monocultures there's kind of
you know this divert biodiversity issue
and then also increase production costs
or are we increasing the environmental
benefits if you think of a weed as a
plant that has some desirable
characteristics so this is a bit of a
conflict and I don't think it's been
resolved completely but if we look back
so historically we're looking back
because we want to know what have we
gone through what have we worked on so
we'd is defined as a plant out of place
I think most of you have heard that
definition but Ralph Waldo Emerson is as
defined as a plant whose virtues have
not yet been discovered so instead of
looking at the glass as half-empty he's
looking at it as half-full so over time
now I've put this this time scale back
in the early days all the way up to here
and you can see that and this is
basically relating to weeds you know
whether we had the first hand implements
then we get into horse-drawn mechanical
the chemical era begins with the first
herbicide where the 240 herbicide
some you know internet was invented in
1973 okay why is that important to weeds
well get into that as far as technology
we have the first herbicide resistant
ryegrass resistant to 27 sites of
actions so if you're familiar with the
herbicide resistance scenario or issue
there's there's different sites of
actions with the different modes of
actions and this rye grass here is
pretty major and this occurred in 1982
if we look at certified organic systems
was certified in the u.s. in 1990 the
executive order and everyone's familiar
with the Clinton era when they declared
invasive species as something that we
need to start managing or they made it
an executive order and now we have
climate hubs developed in 2013 and the
most recent research that I've seen is
the development of an automated wieder
by some folks at UC Davis so these are
kind of some of the events that
contribute to what I'm going to talk
about but in addition to those changes
we've also had you know ecological the
theory has advanced over that same time
period and we've also seen some
practical application in our management
so that's changed whether we're talking
about hand implements all the way up to
an automated wieder okay so we're seeing
a lot of changes over time but I think
also contribute to our viewpoint and are
thinking but weeds and ecosystems
they're either resilient or their pesky
and this is based on kind of perception
but in in these natural ecosystems
semi-natural or urban ecosystems weeds
tend to be survivors they tend to
persist they're very prolific in in
either producing seed or producing
biomass and in some ways you could view
them as opportunistic they look for
niches and I'm giving them kind of human
qualities but niches are what they take
advantage of and and that's really what
we see especially when you look at a lot
of these
in our managed systems there's a lot of
disturbance going on there so there's
opportunities that are created for weeds
so I'm going to talk about kind of three
main areas and this is related to the
things that I have done research on or
what my interests were prior to coming
here and I'm going to just talk about
these three things just to get us
thinking about more broadly as far as
weeds and invasive plants so super weeds
now super weeds is a very it kind of
gets your attention whether it's at the
emotional level or or whatever you've
probably seen it in the popular press
associated with genetically modified
crops so this article by by Cogan in
2005 talked about super weeds are
impossible to kill well they're
impossible to kill if you're using one
herbicide and if it's glyphosate you're
going to have a glyphosate resistant
gene that's either transferred to the
weed or the indiscriminate spring of
life state onto resistant GM crops
you're basically providing selection
pressure to allow for a resistant we
deep Lant ok so herbicide resistant are
they really super weeds well we probably
ought to maybe you've seen this graph
but this is from ian heap and his weed
science website basically we've seen a
dramatic increase in herbicide resistant
weeds and for those of you who don't
know Palmer amaranth in the South in
cotton fields has been a huge issue for
them to deal with and it's actually
forced some growers to even go out of
growing cotton but it's a nice you know
poster child verbs herbicide resistant
weeds again these characteristics
contribute to its success in these
cropping systems so I'm going to take
you through a
a time lapse if you will in 1989 the
first Palmer amaranth resistance was
identified in Tennessee and Georgia if
my geography is correct so South
Carolina thank you we'll get to Georgia
so in 1990-91 93 94 95 97 98 2000 and
I'm just going to go right ahead and
just you can see that continually we're
seeing these plants 2012 and again this
is from the herbicide resistance website
but you can see that in each of these
states at least one individual or one
population has been identified
resistance to herbicide so it is what is
what's going to happen you know onwards
is there going to be just uniform
resistance we hope not but I'm going to
shift gears so there's the resistance
issue but also in my work I was
especially interested in extreme events
and what we're seeing in especially in
the Midwest was significant drought and
significant impacts of drought on
cropping systems and so they've been a
lot of work there's still is a lot of
work on developing drought tolerant
crops corn soybeans things like that but
for as much for what I know there's not
a real interest or there's not a lot of
work in drought tolerant weeds or
invasive plants now I know tony has
written some things and there's some
folks that are working on it but as far
as the real focused effort it's not it's
not a lot of work has been done on that
but just to kind of define it's a delay
and leaf with dehydration usually it's
related to the physiology or morphology
of the plant and we see a phenotypic
plasticity where the plant ela uses less
water it loses less water or it gains
access to water through root penetration
through the ground
and then there's also the genetic
adaptation where over time if there's
another selection pressure that is is
creating a change in the population and
this depends a lot on the intensity and
duration of that selection pressure so
as I indicated in 2012 we saw this chart
from the US Drought Monitor and this
central part of the country was either
red or brown for most of the year so I
looked at phragmites australis which I
think you folks have some of that out
here either good or bad but looking at
Phragmites common read and its tolerance
to drought so we looked we had a
greenhouse study we set up basically we
had these large tanks where we
transplanted Phragmites and then we
submitted or exposed them to different
stress periods and this we had a low
stress medium stress and severe stress
and basically that was related to the
number of days that there was no water
in those music cozzens and so for our
low stress we had 19 days of no water
which in addition there were four days
where it was at greater than eighty
percent available water was depleted so
we're getting down to very very dry
conditions essentially and sour medium
stress was 36 days with no water 20 days
at greater than eighty percent and then
our severe stress basically a month of
no water and out of those out of that 60
days there were about forty four days
where it was significantly dry so what
do we see in our lowest stress treatment
where we had seven this is day 70 so on
on days 70 we added water back into
those tanks and you know looking at this
it would say well that plant is either
dead or it has gone dormant well it was
actually dormant because 25 days post
drought
it had started to green up now this is
just a low-stress I was convinced that
the severe stress we'd killed those
plants I thought they're dead absolutely
well not the case because 25 days later
those plants were starting to green up
and you can ask well did you get all the
water out of that so we had soil
moisture sensors that were basically
reading zero and I know there's you know
there's probably could have been pockets
of water in those systems but very much
an indication that this plant is is very
tolerant to drought conditions and maybe
some of you are familiar with that I've
worked on this particular species
shifting gears a little bit carduelis
newtons which is musta cyl we looked at
an invasion study into cool and warm
season perennial grasses and we had
stimulated grazing for two years we also
introduced musta cyl in the first year
in the spring of the first year and part
of this study was very interesting in
that we had normal precipitation one
year and then we went into our drought
year in 2012 which was the worst drought
that they've had on record so it was
really nice for a study it was horrible
for people that were you know cropping
and and and that part but it worked out
really well for us to compare that so
I'm just going to go right to the
results and then again along the x-axis
here is the the dates so april 2011 all
the way up to november two thousand
twelve and then here's our volumetric
water content these represent the the
various treatments whether it was bare
ground must the soil by itself warm
season grazed warm season non grazed
cool season grade school season on grace
but basically this shows you that in the
second year where we had our must and I
realized these lines are not really easy
for you to see but where there was not
basically non grazing so our non grace
treatments we had there was water
content but where we had our musta soul
and then anything where there was
grazing if I'm reading that right had
depleted water down so we saw a
difference in water content between
these two treatments and this is a
really great graph especially if you're
tired and you want to go to sleep really
easily pardon me for the the busyness
but along here the XX these are all our
treatments and this is basically looking
at light penetration into the canopy
over May June July and August of 2011
and then the same thing in 2012 so so
what I want to highlight is at the
initial part of our study we had good
plant cover so if you think so if you
see a high bar that means there's a lot
of light penetrating into this to the
soil surface if you see a bars that are
low that means there's not a lot of
light reaching the soil surface so
looking at and I'm just going to point
out a couple to treatments are warm
season non Grey's must as'll where we
added it and warm season where we just
added musta soul by itself or sorry warm
season on grades without muscle so you
can see in 2011 it's doing a good job at
shading out the soil surface but in 2012
and now these are perennial grasses they
should be growing robustly you know
providing some good shade in 2012 the
drought was affecting these grasses
where they had now were allowing light
to penetrate the soil surface and you
say well why is that important well from
us though so it's very important and
once it gets access to light with enough
soil moisture it grows very well again
here's the same thing this is just
looking at populations over time so in
2011-2012 I'm just highlighting this our
warm season non grazed where we
introduce muscle so you can see here
early on it started to establish but
then in August it disappeared same thing
in 2012 it started to establish by July
those
plants were dead so what was going on in
2011 we had great soil moisture we had
normal precipitation we had very nice
establishment of muscle in our grazed
treatment in our non graze plots in 2012
this is basically muscle emerging and
then it would die without producing a
flower or any kind of seed head and just
for comparison here's our beautiful bare
ground plots of muscle which we did get
a lot of attention by people driving but
this is right by a highway and they
would drive by and say you need to
control that it was you know because the
noxious weed and we were trying to do
research on it we we were we were we
bagged all the the seed heads so just to
let you know we didn't let all the seed
just go everywhere we were we were
bagging the seed heads and then the
second year we chopped all this down and
I I did actually get a chance to operate
a shovel and take care of any remaining
so but this is just too just a little
bit of a kind of an introduction of
where we're seeing this tolerance or not
tolerating these dry drought conditions
so does tolerant or resistance make it
super well we also know that there's
there's weeds that are tolerant to
mowing they're tolerant to disking or
disturbances it's really dependent on
intensity and duration and it's not
super but they're actually resilient so
fina logically or genetically it adapts
to environmental stress whether you know
an examples drought it these plants are
able to evolve as far as their defense
mechanisms you know and this is an
example of herbicides and they're also
able to access spatial-temporal
resources whether that's light water
nutrients now I I'm saying this related
to weeds but again they're just plants
they're not you know some formidable foe
that is
that is that we can't really deal with
and I'll talk about that at the end as
well so bioenergy I'm going to shift
gears here a little bit bioenergy
research this is just a map of where
some of the regional projects have been
conducted across the country and this is
a little bit dated it's not really up to
date but just to show you and I think
everyone is aware of the bioenergy
research that's going on there's several
resources there's several things folks
are looking at obviously corn corn
residue switchgrass perennial grasses
has been some interest in Miscanthus
giganteus biodiesel soybeans canola
camila camelina and others I just want
to point out there's even within this
group there's folks looking at brass
file energy but there's also been some
interest in invasive plants as bio
energy sources and if you look at these
three photos the thing sorry for my math
is not working real long you can see
that there's high amounts of biomass
right that's that's the big interest is
how can we create a lot of biomass to
you know create ethanol and and provide
some fuel well like we discussed for
palmer invasive plants have some similar
characteristics are fast-growing high
biomass relatively few pests they create
these dense monocultures and there's few
inputs to kind of keep them going but on
the flip side of that they that is a
great scenario for invasion and there's
there's a lot of potential with these
plants some have already you know some
of already are already doing they're
invasive work the weed risk assessments
is it anyone familiar a free weed risk
assessment so assessing a plant for its
it's invasive or its ability to become a
problem most of these assessments on
these
ansar positive there it's their highly
problematic or they could be highly
problematic peer-reviewed position
papers these are just two of many papers
that have opposed this kind of a you
know use of these invasive plants as
well as public land managers I mean when
you say hey guess what we're going to
use these for bioenergy they say are you
crazy because it's it's a it's the thing
that we're always managing and then
somehow you want to protect that to
create a fuel source well a new approach
I think is important here and this gets
back to what how do we think about this
and if we're harvesting existing
populations and the focus is on control
and restoration I think it's a little
bit different scenario and also if we
can commingle these sources with other
resources you address the sustainability
issue so there's a paper in frontiers in
in 2013 they basically looked at
bioenergy that sports ecological
restoration and they were focused on
these two invasive plants Russian olive
and tamarisk in Washington State they
had a 52-acre restoration site and this
is this was all a model they did this by
modeling so there wasn't actual you know
it wasn't an actual field study but they
looked at you know all the available
Tamra's Russian olive kind of assess the
biomass and found out that you know
there was a significant amount that
could be produced per year and they
estimated four decades so they compared
their data to national estimates and
basically what they came up with was
that they said we could they could
expand restoration activities and
biomass supplies which would then create
revenue well so it would be supported by
revenues from the sale of the invasive
tree would way so basically you're
supporting that that that restoration
effort by the sale
of the invasive plant biomass so you're
trying to create this system that
supports itself so I'd seen that I'd
already been thinking about this and I
submitted numerous proposals with other
colleagues different disciplines you
know just an example of some of the
proposals we submitted we've submitted
to numerous funding sources requesting
up to 15 million dollars with zero
funded so if anyone is interested in
this if you want to pursue this I'd be
happy to talk to you about it but just
realize what you're up against and then
and and I'm going to show you some of
the barriers of why ok so it's an
ideological you know how are we thinking
about this there's environmental risk we
already know that there's a weed risk
and even if you're transporting this
stuff there's potential that okay you
could distribute it you know in the in
the pathway somewhere economical I've
run into this over and over you know
these plants are not sustainable if we
harvested everything there wouldn't be
enough to supply the energy needs that
we're looking at you know so it's not a
particularly energy dense material
there's social issues conflicting of
national agendas so the Department of
Energy says hey grow this stuff yet the
USDA says no we need to control it so
you know you can't it's hard to go to
them and propose something when there's
not really agreement between agencies so
we're going through all this we're
having this really good discussion
meanwhile the invasive plants continue
spread because they don't really care
what we think okay so but this is just
some ideas that that I've been thinking
about and working on in when I was my
previous location so the last thing I
want to talk about is automation and
just to preface that so in agriculture
looked at you know some of the trends
that are occurring and we've looked
we've seen that land use in Ag has
dropped from 54 to 51%
so that's you know kind of holding
steady labour decline thirty percent
while agricultural predict productivity
increased fifty percent larger farms
ninety-seven percent family-owned I I
guess I'm not going to question I mean
this is a report by the USDA but the
thing I want to really point out here is
the increased adoption of new
technologies and that's really what
we're seeing in some of our cropping
systems but in addition to that we're
kind of we've got these challenges that
we're trying to address whether they're
limited resources water nutrients energy
we have conditions that are that are
continually we're dealing with whether
they're pests diseases disasters and now
we're seeing you know climate change
extreme events but there's also
challenges to innovation the application
logistics as well as the one we always
like to work on is funding but what is
the available what is the technology
that's out there what are you know what
is kind of the new thing that that is on
the horizon are actually being developed
well in our human health system or human
health area they now have cameras that
can you can actually swallow and they
can look inside you different you know
find different things that are right or
wrong I don't know if that's good or bad
you can you they could unlock your car
from space now we've all gone through
this one where you're going through the
airport and they can see everything and
then this one with you know they can
determine if you've washed your hands
because their sensors that that show
what's actually been done so that you
know could be beneficial if you have a
two or three year old and you tell them
what to do and they don't always do it
and then here is the one for all you
gamers out there that just you know like
to get in these now these games are
getting real interactive and you can
actually play you know across geographic
locations and but this is the kind of
technology
that probably is nothing new to a lot of
you and there's even other things going
on but I just thought this this a new
biology for the 21st century they point
out that you know computational Sciences
and engineers are part of this
biological research that's going on this
emerging trend and this is a quote from
Bill Gates back in two thousand eight on
the special edition on robotics and
basically says when or even if this
industry robotics will achieve critical
mass if it does it may well change the
world well we're six years later and I
think we're seeing some of those changes
evenly in our cropping systems here's
John Reed a director of production
technology at John Deere and they're
saying that opportunities to follow a
different path to higher productivity
one that involves automation control and
robotics so you've seen their 48th row
planter but they're also looking at very
small individual robots that move in the
field and and and that's an area that
that these companies are looking at as
well so what is the idea with this
automation stuff well if we've got weeds
in our cropping system we want to
produce this we want to support these
people but we also want to maintain our
natural resources our economics but we
don't necessarily want to revert to that
so how do we do all this and can we you
know use automation to help in this
process if we talk about integrated weed
management a lot of treatment factors
that that contribute to the decisions
that need to be made and I'm not going
to go into detail on these but selection
method application amount timing plant
conditions environmental conditions
these are some of the factors that are
considered an integrated weed management
and then you think about well if we're
talking automation we've got machine
factors that include logistics if we're
working in real time
and then also guidance if you're talking
about something that's that's autonomous
so targeted recognition and application
systems actually are possible and I'm
going to show you some examples of
research if you look at the the
literature on on engineering they're
really working in this weed science area
more than maybe some of the weed
scientists so they're kind of doing this
work and I think there's a real
opportunity for overlap or collaboration
between these two fields so if we talk
about the spatial-temporal
identification and management of weeds
basically predicting where the weeds are
based on environmental factors we're
really good at predicting not always
versus treatable based on location and
plant characteristics so I'm going to
focus on this one just in the in the in
the next few minutes so based on
location so locating the weeds and
there's some I think there's been work
done you know where are weeds in the
field how do we find those do you go
through and you know do it by hand you
do it with sensors or computers but you
can create these maps and this is a
comparison of maps created either by
manual weed mapping so going out and
mapping those by hand semi-automated
weed mapping kind of a hybrid between
hand weeding or hand by hand versus
using technology and then on automated
weed mapping and you can see that there
they're pretty close there there's some
relationship there and what they found
was the weed density in in most cases
the difference was due to leaf occlusion
so when you've got overlapping weeds
it's it's hard for the technology to
identify well this is a weed and this is
separate that just looks at it as one
weed so that's part
the issue with why there's not a real
nice relationship with doing those two
but if we we talked about locate so we
know okay we look in the field where are
they what about plant characteristics
can we look at some of the
characteristics of the plant to help us
identify some of this and this early
work was back in the 1980s looking at
sunflowers and soybeans and basically
looking at near infrared photography but
we've obviously did we've advanced from
that from that point on in the early
1990s they've developed these commercial
spot sprayers basically looking at if
there's green foliage or brown soil so
when the green comes up that's you know
an indication to spray but we're getting
beyond that now we're getting to where
we've got some a knowledge-based machine
vision system and its kind of based on
on these principles you could you know
view this as a decision support tool but
visually you know finding where the
plants are and then through a series of
steps identifying those plants and then
even going to the species classification
and population and then we can develop a
weed map that's very specific and and
allows us to have a strategic approach
this right here is the hard part you can
find the plants but getting to
individual leaflets looking at least
shape venation texture analysis species
classification this is the the problem
with this particular approach so here's
an example this is from the norwegian
crop institute and they tried to do some
of this work looking at plant canopy
that was photographed and doing this on
the go as well so this is not a stop you
know view and then well it's it's a real
time system because trying to get this
to a practical application is going to
require us to go at a certain speed
so we've got a knowledge basement
machine system and application system
and this is again some the work by the
the group at UC Davis and basically this
schematic shows you that travelling in
this direction with this camera image
processing computer and then connecting
it to a microcontroller where okay we've
identified the weeds now can we spray
those based on the information that we
collected going through the field and
they've showed some success especially
where they can distinguish tomato from
nightshade and pigweed foliage so it's
very right now it's very rudimentary but
they're really making some good nice
progress in that way so here's another
of you know looking at it again looking
at the shape but also now adding the
visual color looking at you know what
are the differences in the color of the
plants can we use that to help us
identify it and most recently this group
has been awarded a grant to look at
doing kind of what they said here is is
is modifying the color of that plant to
then allow them to differentiate between
the weeds and the plant now what is this
going to at what effect is that going to
have on the production of the plant I
don't know I that's yet to be seen but
but just you know changing this color
you know using in this case a a gene
that could be a way to help kind of
identify our desirable plants vs. weeds
so true integrated weed management I
think we have an opportunity to actually
you know pursue this now that we have
technology so we have sensors that can
locate individual weeds in the field
weeds can be identified based on their
characteristics or using a database and
then the decision support system
determines the best
treatment now the the part that is as
important as is as we're working at the
microscale and this is again a little
bit of a conceptual challenge and it's
not for a field that's just loaded with
weeds that's not the intent I it's it
the intent is were you where you've got
some weed management challenges and you
can have a robotic system go through
identify where the weeds are if there's
a known herbicide-resistant weed that
computer can identify it and apply a
different treatment whether it's a you
know a cutting treatment of burning
treatment but again it has to be at the
micro dose level so advanced technology
can't account for spatial temporal
variability and since we have all tools
on board they're available at any time
and any location and field so you're
you're bringing integrated weed
management to the field you're not
waiting for different seasons you're not
rotating crops not that you that you
shouldn't be doing that but those tools
are there in real time so conception to
the field these are some of the things
this is a swarm technology right now I
don't know if some of you've heard about
that they have these individual kind of
spider looking robots that that kind of
move throughout the field and they have
a little area that they they manage
there's also some of these automated
machines that that they're looking at
where the weeds are and then they they
have actuators that that move you know
within the crow these are used in row
crops so that you know the question are
we still at research-grade I think we
still are there I know there's some
startup companies in California that are
actually you know working in this area
and they're actually making some really
nice advances but in general I think
we're still kind of looking at okay how
do we make this thing work and how do we
do it efficiently so I'm just going to
wrap up here with just some final
thoughts so I think I think what was
needed is
kind of emerging of attitudes not at
emerging but merging and so what type of
thinking do we need to have and I don't
really think it's convention or
sustainable I think it's outside the box
thinking I think just a different
approach and be thinking broadly not
like our second photograph where the
young man was thinking are you kidding
me this is not a new frontier so you
know I think our mindset needs to change
about how do we view weeds and so what
do we need to be thinking about weeds
are plants you know some and some happen
to be very resilient so what can we
learn from those plants met our managing
weeds when is it necessary for complete
control as compared to when can we use
thresholds is there a time when we we
can allow a weed or does it always have
to be you know annihilated advanced
technology is part of our society how
can we enhance our tools in the
integrated weed management tool box I
think some of those things are up and
coming and there's either even other
things that I didn't mention that are
that are applicable and we all know that
weeds are ubiquitous so what ecosystem
services are some weeds providing and
how can those services not the weeds be
exploited you know so what can we if
they're here we're dealing with them are
there some ways that we can actually
incorporate them into our system in a
way that doesn't become detrimental to
our economics and our environment in
other ways so that's all I have and I'd
be happy to answer any questions I think
we have maybe a few minutes or so
that's that's a very good question in
fact one of the things that I was I was
working on before I left UNL was
training livestock to eat invasive
plants so there is a person in Colorado
and maybe some of you familiar but she
has trained cows to eat weeds just
google it and you'll bring up her
website but in Nebraska beef is like the
number one commodity in in life's you
know in animal systems so you've already
got him out there why can't you just
train him to eat the things that you
don't want and she showed that you could
do that now I had some there was it was
not as simple as it sounds but I that's
a very very good you no idea whether
it's genetically modifying them or just
training them to eat these these plants
that we don't necessarily want that's a
very good question and it's a good segue
to my presentation that i will be giving
in a couple weeks to the department of
natural resources on invasive plants and
ecology so when I was at UNL I had to
basically balance agri agronomic weeds
invasive plants so I I cut a generalized
for this audience it's the agronomic
side but the invasive plants you know
are very much obviously like you said
they're less intensively managed so how
do we address that it just had a
conversation with with carry the two
carries before I got it like where do we
say okay you know am I am I making any
difference here may I making any
progress on especially at large scale
and I think that's where it really comes
down to defining what your goals are
especially when we talked to land
managers you know is is it a problem
across your entire landscape do you have
patches you have satellite populations
where you can you know focus on those I
think that's where we're we're really
looking at removing those and and and
gets back to that restoration study by
those the folks that you know in
frontiers and but that's that's a maybe
an equally as large or bigger question
but it's a good point all right well
times up so let's hang Steve once again
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu